let's get the view from labor now I can
talk to the shadow Health secretary
where's streeting uh Mrs treating really
good to talk to you today thanks very
much for joining us especially giving up
good morning is outside
um we're talking uh about aside from the
football uh the state of the NHS strikes
uh the current state of the NHS and and
you've written an interesting piece in
the Sunday Telegraph today
um you say that after the pandemic there
are no quick fixes for the NHS and that
you're terrified by the state of it what
would labor do first and why
so the center of Labor's plans to make
the NHS fit for the future is the
biggest expansion of the NHS Workforce
in history Because unless we have the
staff we need we won't be able to give
patients the timely access to care that
they deserve that so that would be the
biggest expansion of the NHS staff in
history doubling the number of medical
school places increasing nursing and
Midwifery clinical training places by
ten thousand five thousand more Health
visitors and doubling the number of
District nurses and we would pay for it
by abolishing the non-dom tax status
because we think that people who make
Britain their home should pay their
taxes here too and this is a fair way of
funding that something that's
desperately needed Because unless you've
got a plan for the workforce you don't
have a plan for the NHS and
unfortunately that's the terrible
situation this government has found
itself in and that's the difference a
labor government would make your critics
would say that that abolishing non-dom
status is something of a cheap shot to
get at the Prime Minister and his
personal circumstances what is the
evidence that it actually would bring in
that money because some would say that
actually the very wealthy will simply
take the best advice and move themselves
and their money elsewhere and deny it to
the treasury and and also that your
plans yes you're talking about far more
staff members which will be enormously
welcomed in the NHS but for example
doctors getting more doctors through the
system this takes years and years you're
talking
solutions that will help in five to ten
years time
so I say a few things in response I mean
firstly the figures we've used in the
analysis we've used is independent
produced by academics at Warwick
University and the London School of
Economics it would generate more than
three billion pounds that's more than
enough to cover the 1.6 billion that our
package would cost and as for these uh
claims that people would just go take
their money and and go somewhere else
why is it that when it comes to taxing
the wealthy it's always far too
difficult but when it comes to picking
the pockets of working people with
punitive tax Rises that seems to be the
conservatives first and last resort uh
and look we haven't taken this policy to
single out the Prime Minister and his
family actually but there is a case in
point in 10 Downing Street isn't there
of someone who was a non-dom now pays
their taxes here and hasn't left the
country and I think that would be the
case in the vast majority of non-doms
too and while I understand that the
chancellor wants good relations with his
next-door neighbors who doesn't I do
think this is a fair way of funding a
Workforce plan which Jeremy Hunt himself
welcomed when labor first announced it
and he said and these are his words the
smart governments Nick the best ideas of
his opponents well I'm saying this
morning Jeremy you're welcome to Nick
Labor's Workforce plan we need to get
our skates on recruiting the doctors and
nurses and other staff the NHS needs
you're welcome to Nick the plan and in
the meantime Sophie there are things the
government can and should be doing right
now to alleviate the crisis in the NHS
this winter whether that's using spare
beds in the private sector so that we
pay for people to get seen faster so
it's free at the point of use for them
but much quicker using that capacity
available whether it's dealing with the
pensions issues that see doctors leaving
the NHS early retiring early for no
other reason than their pension rules
create a financial disincentive to stay
on or whether it's actually just pulling
their finger out and even where they're
trying to do the right thing like the
half a billion pounds to deal with
delayed discharge in Social care do you
know not a penny of that money has hit
the front line yet why because of all
the chaos we saw over the summer
changing from Health secretary to health
secretary from prime minister to prime
minister I'm afraid the conservatives
incompetence and chaos is costing the
country dear but there are things they
can and should be doing we're calling on
them to take that action but ultimately
I think it's clear now after 12 years
that the longer the conservatives are in
power the longer patients will wait
you're talking about the conservatives
nicking your ideas but looking at this
this piece that you've written it seems
like you're nicking a lot of theirs
you've just referred to using the price
private sector more and some would be
astonished at seeing this policy coming
from from a labor politician you've also
talked about the BMA who we are going to
be talking to later on in the program as
vested interests you say that they see
you as a heretic for wanting better
patient access and you're going to take
them on
um how do you think these lines will go
down with traditional labor voters
well the last Labor government
successfully used the private sector to
bring down an HS waiting list and you
know by the end of that labor government
use of the private sector had fallen
dramatically because the NHS was so good
that people didn't feel the need to go
private any longer and and as for the
question of values I think it's
outrageous we've got a two-tier
healthcare system in this country today
where those who can pay to go private do
and those who can't afford to go private
are left behind or indeed there are some
people that are scrimping and scraping
even getting themselves into dare in
order to get seen faster that's not a
fair and Equitable situation that's not
the NHS living up to its founding
principles and I think it's the right
thing to do to create a Level Playing
Field using empty beds in the private
sector so that people can see be seen
faster and as for the BMA I mean I was
just responding in that interview of the
telegraph to criticism they leveled at
me because despite the fact that I
announced the big biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history because I had the
temerity to to say that we should also
expect better service for patients in
exchange for that investment because I I
think that it's unacceptable that people
have to wait on the phone at eight
o'clock in the morning to get through to
GP I have been treated like some kind of
heretic by the BMA and I'm afraid you
know I do understand the pressure that
doctors are under they do a very
difficult job against very difficult
backdrop but what I'm saying is if we're
putting investment into the NHS as the
next Labor government will we have got
to expect a better results for patients
and ultimately it's my job to be the
patience Champion I'm a patient myself
I've had great experience on the NHS
I've also had not great experience on
the NHS I want to make sure that
everyone in this country gets a great
experience and that we've got an NHS
that's fit for the future but but as the
man who could very soon be Health
secretary it doesn't sound like you've
got a really great relationship from the
start with the doctors unions
uh look my I'm always willing to engage
with the BMA in fact on the doctor's
pensions issue where they've made a
reasonable Point as they did on that
issue I'm prepared to run with it but
what I'm not prepared to do is just
accept lower standards for patients
because people think that it's
unachievable to expect that people
should be able to book a GP appointment
online or see the doctor they want to
face to face get faster treatment I do
understand the pressures that are on NHS
staff today that's why we're proposing
to dramatically increase NHS num
Staffing numbers that's why on issues
like retention of the staff we have
we're both urging the government to act
on doctors pensions but also urging them
to be grown up and get around the table
with the unions that are preparing to go
on strike who even at this 11th Hour are
saying there is a deal to be done I mean
the Royal College of Nursing and Unison
have said just last night that if the
government is prepared to sit down and
talk about pay and all of the other
issues they will spend strike action
this week now I think that is an offer
that is too good to refuse and I want
the government to explain why they're
not prepared to sit down and even talk
even though they know that patients will
experience real disruption as a result
of strike actions
that's responsible
earlier and he said that the health
secretary's door is open but that is up
to the independent pay review bodies to
make a ruling on pay
um you also said in this piece that the
energy but the government's lines are
jokes so there's a joke on that Sophie
the government's line is a complete joke
on that there hasn't been a single
minute of negotiation you've got the
General Secretary of the Royal College
of Nursing and the General Secretary of
Unison saying they will suspend strike
action this week if the government will
talk they've not even said if the
government you know rolls over and
accepts the entirety of their pay demand
they have said very reasonably if the
government talks will be there and will
suspend strike action it is completely
unreasonable for the government not to
want to negotiate and I think they are
spoiling with a fight I think they don't
have a plan for the NHS this winter
they're quite happy to see paramedics
and nurses go on strike because when the
proverbial hits the fan this winter they
are going to blame nurses and paramedics
for an NHS crisis which is squarely the
fault of a conservative government and
12 years of mismanagement I think that's
dangerous I think it's reprehensible I
think it's irresponsible and I think
patients will likely blame the
government not the unions if these
strikes go ahead okay well let's talk
money then what pay Rises would the
labor party give NHS workers that let's
look at the NHS itself there are nine
bands and NHS payers I'm sure you know
let's look sort of in the middle fan
four-ish a theater support worker this
is the person that holds your hand when
the anesthetics going into your arm make
sure that you're all right make sure the
surgeon has all the tools that they need
they're currently on around 24 to 26 000
pounds a year which is about
12 to 13 pounds an hour
what would labor give them what do you
think would be a fair pay rise
so we would be willing to negotiate
Sophie and negotiate on Pay The Wider
terms and conditions and the way that
the independent pay review Body Works
I'm not going to pluck numbers out of
thin air this morning not least because
a labor Government after an election
that's probably going to be in around
two years time
you shouldn't be doing
no no no I don't want to be
misunderstood on that point Sophie what
I said is that we would look at how the
pay review Body Works because when I
have been talking to the RCN Unison GMB
and unite um they raise a whole range of
issues yes around pay and the terms and
conditions that staff are working under
which I think are intolerable but
they've also talked about the
independence of the pay review body and
the way it works I'd be willing to look
at all of those scrap the current issues
engage seriously
it's important that we have independent
pay review bodies and I think the unions
have raised some legitimate concerns
about how they work I'd be willing to
look at that but what I'm not prepared
to do Sophie this morning is to create
hostages to Fortune and worse still make
promises for two years time that I may
not be able to keep because when I come
on your program and say the labor party
will deliver the biggest expansion of
NHS staff in history is because I can
guarantee what it would cost how we
would pay for it and the decision it
would make that's the approach we're
taking to all of our policies and
sometimes I know it's frustrating for
people who want us to go further faster
and for all of the campaign and Lobby
groups who want us to adopt this policy
or that policy but the conservatives
have crashed the economy the public
finances are in a real mess and I want
to make sure as all of us in the labor
party do that when we go into the
election the public can have confidence
sense that we can keep the promises that
we make so my message to the government
today is get around the table of the
unions you you convert strike action the
unions are being entirely reasonable on
this negotiate today avert strike action
and will be willing to talk to the
unions about how we make sure that the
staff who are currently in the NHS feel
valued how we get the economy growing
again so that we can invest in our
public services and improve people's pay
without having to resort to higher taxes
that the conservatives had and and to
work together on the NHS said it's fit
for the future
okay we're nearly out of time but I just
wanted to ask you a little bit about the
relationship between the labor party and
the unions we've had further allegations
this week about the United Union two
reports being handed over to the police
um from its own review and into what
happened there when you look at the
allegations that there are do you think
it's time for the labor party to step
back from from the way it is funded
relying on the unions for so much of its
funding do you think it is time to to
think again about how your party is
funded
what were two things firstly I think the
current General Secretary of unite
Sharon Graham deserves enormous credit
for being willing to open the books and
go through them call in the
investigators to make sure that her
members Subs are properly used and I
think the findings we've seen are deeply
worrying but you know it takes guts to
uncover the levels of of wrongdoing that
appear to have taken place in unite and
I think she deserves credit for that the
second thing is the labor party was
founded by the trade unions to stand up
for the interests of working people that
throughout our history I think has been
a strength we don't always agree we
can't always say yes to every demand
that the trade unions make but I think
what the trade Union link has done
throughout Labor's history is root Us in
the experiences and the interests of
ordinary working people who without the
labor party would not have a voice in
British politics because as a
conservatives have shown us throughout
their their history they act in the
interests of a privileged few at the top
the labor party exists to serve the
interests of the many that's the
fundamental dividing line in British
politics and that has never been more
true than it is today
okay we're streating very good to talk
to you thank you very much